Und wie alt sind Sie, Herr Wagner?
Ich bin genau 60.
Wann wurden Sie genau geboren? Heute ist Ihre Gebissheit.
Am 1.7.65.
Ein... und...
Können Sie bitte noch mal sagen, es wird ein...
Am 1.7.65.
Und herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Wieso erst liebsten? Das ist Juli.
Sorry.
Juli.
Ja, sorry.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie so seid?
Ich bin noch 74 kg und ich bin 1.83 groß.
Okay, Herr Wagner, haben Sie sehr stark geschmätzt?
Seit wann haben Sie tatsächlich so viel geschmätzt?
Ja, das hat angefangen, ja, bestimmt schon.
Vor einem Viertel, ja, so.
Aber jetzt wird es in der letzten Zeit, in den letzten 2, 3 Wochen,
ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Und also hier oben im Bauch tut das sowieso so unterhalb der Brust,
oben unterhalb vom Bauchnabel, würde ich sagen, ja.
Oh, und das sind solche Schmerzen.
Das zieht und ja, ist jetzt also in letzter Zeit richtig schlecht geworden.
Okay, wann treten diese Schmerzen auf,
nach dem Essen oder nach dem bestimmten Bewegungen?
Na ja, ich würde sagen, sie sind ein... ich permanent da.
Okay, Herr Weber, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre.
59, wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1.7.65.
75 oder 60?
65. 60.
Also 99,65.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,83.
83.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Wie viel so 74 Kilo.
Herr Schöller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 32 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 23. März, 1900.
Was ist das? 82?
92, wahrscheinlich.
92, 92.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,82 Meter.
32.
Wie sind Sie Ihr aktuelles Gewicht?
Ja, ungefähr 85 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Dingardissen?
Ich bin 64.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. Januar, 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,81 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle, wie sind Sie?
82 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Baumann?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Okay. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 4. Juli, 181.
81.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter groß.
1,78 Meter.
70.
70. Okay.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Etwa 85 Kilo.
85.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Baumann?
Ne.
Ich habe keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Ja, super.
Also wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Doktor Raab.
Doktor Raab?
Raab, R, A, A, B.
R, A, A, B?
Okay, alles klar.
Heimüller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 69 noch.
69.
Okay.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 18.
9.
54.
Okay.
Heimüller, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74 Meter.
74.
Okay.
Und kennen Sie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
Ja, das ist so immer um die 83 Kilo, mal ein bisschen weniger,
mal ein bisschen mehr, aber 83 Kilo kann man sagen.
Okay.
Heimüller, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rentner zum Glück.
Rentner? Ah, okay.
Ja, genau.
Aber was haben Sie früher beruflich gemacht?
Ich war in der Stadtverwaltung angestellt.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich war Angestellter in der Stadtverwaltung.
Okay.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind aber schon Erwachsenen.
Ah, okay.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei, aber wie gesagt, die sind Erwachsenen, ne?
Na okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Ja, 54.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1.15.1970.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Das habe ich, ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen kleiner geworden.
Ich war mal 1,78.
70? Okay.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich sage so wichtig, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin ein bisschen etwas schwer.
Ich glaube, so bei 110 Kilo.
110? Ja.
Alle Informationen sind wichtig,
über Ihre allgemeine Gesundheit zu wissen.
Danke schön für die Informationen.
Ja.
Und wie alt sind Sie und wann wurden Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Geboren bin ich am 15. Mai 1971.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wegen Sie so seid?
Ich bin 1,67 Meter groß und wiege 64 Kilo.
64 Kilo.
Verstehe, wie alt sind Sie, Herr Eidim?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28. April 1900.
Was ist das, 83?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, 1 Meter 83.
Und wie viel wegen Sie?
So circa 75 Kilo.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Zimmermann?
Ich bin 67.
67? Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 2. Mai 1957.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin so 1,75.
Wie viel wegen Sie?
Ich wiege 78 Kilo.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Schmidt.
Mit DET am Ende?
Ja, genau.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 37 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 1988 geworden.
1980?
1988.
Ach so, genau dort?
Ach so, 25. Januar.
Danke schön.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin ungefähr 1 Meter 80 groß.
Und wiege momentan 75 Kilogramm.
Danke schön, Herr Schmidt.
Okay, Frau Hansen, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 1.5. 1961.
Frau Hansen, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68.
60?
Und kennen Sie Ihr aktuellen Gewicht?
Ich habe aktuellen Gewicht um 74 Kilogramm.
Plus, minus, mal ein bisschen mehr, mal ein bisschen weniger.
Okay, 74 Kilogramm.